meanwhile a dieter announcement about
work search requirements has left a lot
of
unemployment claimants quite worried
yeah the announcement came over the
weekend and now
a lot of people need answers joe moeller
spoke to some claimants about this and
he's live outside their offices tonight
with more joe
the claimants who are worried about this
are the pua claimants those are the gig
workers or independent contractors they
were allowed to file for unemployment
after the pandemic began
well over the weekend there was an
announcement that they will be included
on the work search requirements and now
many are confused about
how exactly they will do that
i'm a tribute artist for joan rivers
barbara brighton is an entertainer in
las vegas
i have to be called to do what i do
i can't go out and look for jobs come
may 2nd all unemployment claimants
including pool claimants have to prove
work searches
pua claimants are independent
contractors or gig workers
so many are left confused about how to
do this moving forward
tribute artists or entertainers or or
musicians because basically
they can't go out and get the jobs they
have to be called
to fill those jobs pua also known as
pandemic unemployment assistance was
created after the pandemic started and
for the first time ever gig workers and
independent contractors were able to
file for
unemployment up until next month the
work search portion has been waived
what most people may see in their
portals starting in may
is them being required and perhaps not
even able to move on
with their claim if they don't input
some type of information
work search for claimants who were
regular w-2 employees is not new
over the weekend dieter announced on
social media that this will include pua
workers as well
amber hansen from the apua assistance
facebook group says many pool claimants
situations
are different some of the you know
stipulations and requirements for work
search really don't
fit in at all with the poo aside and and
what was kind of troubling to me was
that you know
you know like i tell my claimants all
the time this could change at any moment
dieter told 8 news now monday more
information would come out soon
regarding work search requirements but
they did not say when
the heart of the problem is that we have
to really get better at communicating we
have to
now back out here live peter said that
the week that this wall start is the
week of may 2nd
now as soon as we get some more
information or some uh
information about this uh you
information that you'll need to know
to submit your uh work search we'll be
sure to pass that along so you can stay
with us here for the very latest on that
reporting live outside the data office
joe mohler 8 news now